[Music]
there is a
woman
woman
that's a white woman yeah
who has been awarded more than 2.7
million dollars
in compensation after she discovered a
male colleague with the same job title
and responsibilities was earning fifty
four thousand dollars more than she was
way too whoa don't like that wait two
point what million which part do you not
like how she got paid so much yeah why
don't you get that
it's absurd but does it got 2.7 million
in compensation does the article say how
long each has been at the job
i don't ask those kinds of questions i i
try to just go like i believe the woman
you know what i'm saying
because you're supposed to progressively
i [ __ ] with you bro thank you bro
progressive man so stacy mackin reported
a culture of sex discrimination
victimization and unequal pay at french
bank bnp paribas where she worked as a
prime financial specialist
mackin has now won the 2.7 million
dollars in compensation which is one of
the largest awards ever made by a
british tribunal probably because a man
lawyer helper get that money wait it's a
french bank trial in britain
uh so it's a french bank in britain i
guess so i don't know is this something
where they just do such an enormous sum
just to scare the [ __ ] out of everybody
i'm like hey don't do this [ __ ] like is
that what it's about because like
there's no way
she actually realized two point whatever
the [ __ ] million dollars worth of damage
is like that's so hard for me to get my
head around maybe it's a scale over time
have to work what if she's the
difference was 54 000 she'd have to work
what 40 years unless it's like emotional
damage well actually this is trial tried
in uk and europe right is it uk yeah so
they have different um laws when it
comes to limits and statutes for uh
suing
so it's they don't they're not sue happy
like the u.s because it's not that
profitable out there in the same manner
so she probably had a really tight case
for someone to pick it up and go like
dude you you clearly were 2.6 huh so
judge emma burns claimed mackin's male
bosses acted spitefully and vindictively
and increased her compensation because
the bank failed to apologize to her the
banker was hired by bnp paribus on a
salary of 160 000
in 2013 following her role as vice
president at deutsche bank she later
discovered a male recruit was hired with
the same job title and responsibilities
but paid 216 000 wow okay i take it all
back deutsche bank is a [ __ ] joke
anyway
they had they had multiple vice
presidents
let them pay what do you know about
deutsche bank deutsche bank dude they've
been so fraudulent over the years
they're doing bags you should look it up
joyce bank is a [ __ ] joke 100
so wait that sounds like a german big
it's a french bank
that sounds german that's in the uk it
may have been a german bank and then a
french company bought them
following so confusing following her
role as vice president at deutsche bank
so she was a vice president there and
then got hired by bnp parabus
okay so she's at bmp okay okay she's
abby she got poached okay and then her
male counterpart was being paid 216 000
relatively speaking
this is all in pounds but obviously i'm
giving the calculations
yeah this is like hollywood when the
female actresses are like the pay gap
right yeah i want to be paid like my
male co-star the thing is in hollywood i
don't know why they never explained this
in any of the articles but like
let's say like um bart's an actor and
i'm an actor and joe's an actor and um
bart started before we did he started
like year before and then joe started
six months before i did and then i i
started
uh the latest if we go for a job bart's
gonna get paid the most because he has
the most experience so it's not a gender
thing it's not a gender thing it's about
it's not it's not a project's thing like
let's say i have like way more on my
imdb they do it by hour so they do it by
experience so like let's say you have
like five credits under your belt
you every time you work you get paid a
little bit more unless you're you're the
minimum that's how the union works so
you get paid a little bit more and then
now what i know some women they have
merits and their complaints that oh like
we're getting paid less in market value
okay that's a little bit different but
to say like i need to get paid like my
male co-stars now if you've been working
longer than your male co-stars then yes
you should be getting actually more than
your middle co-stars because it's based
on your last rate
and they'll base it so if you work from
tv to future films they'll tabulate the
hours you work in tv and then they'll in
future films it's like a month as
opposed to like nine months so they'll
divide it and be like okay this is what
you should be getting paid but if a
woman just started
and then she said i want to get paid
equal to my meal co-star and my clothes
are 70. that's just greedy that's just
greed right there that's not the way
it's not gender at all it's just like
it's like an intern coming in and they
want to get paid as much as the ceo
because they're like yo the the male ceo
gets this much and i'm a female intern
yeah actually we imagine well you have
to hold the same role in response this
is like the crazy ridge asian script
script thing you know what i'm talking
about what was that there was a
partnership um with the script of crazy
rich asians and then like um they were
negotiating for the sequel oh the writer
wasn't getting paid as much one of the
writers wasn't getting paid much but
like exactly you're talking about it's
similar one of them had more way more
under their belt than you when you're a
new writer they don't need to pay you
like 300 000 or a million dollars
because you're new yeah your your
awesome like credit is that you have a
credit now for lack of a better word so
when it's a new rider and they're like
well look the success of the movie is
great okay but it's not it's not um it's
not forced upon production companies to
pay you more just because your first
movie did well they they can but they
don't have to
you know um if you like it'd be like
this it'd be like if i as an actor i get
into a movie with julia roberts
and
she's a female lead i'm the male lead
and then i'm like hey but i want to get
paid 20 million dollars just like julia
roberts
makes no sense i know that's an extreme
example but no you just get one make out
you're the male lead you're gonna love
scene with her anyway you [ __ ] pay
for this [ __ ] exactly
give me a break i want to see you in a
movie with julia roberts
awesome she is
at least humping her in a bed with a
sheet over here forget forgetting
notting hill which is kind of
into julia roberts as most people oh
you're wrong have you seen her legs
yeah dude oh yeah
i didn't realize that that's what i
should have had
have you seen her in mystic pizza no
have you seen her and erin brockovich
dude yes thank you you gotta watch miss
thank you
and and
annabelle who's your julia roberts she
looks great in a hooker outfit oh yeah
yeah actually wasn't her body no
get the [ __ ] out it was a body double in
the poster
i still liked it in the movie i guess i
don't have the standards that you have
walter's like i don't know about the
movie but the poster yeah
who's your julia roberts
uh is julia roberts like your number one
in hollywood oh no but she's just hot
she's like
like a timeless beautiful lady
charlize stan okay yeah she's a
good-looking she's a girl
she's a little bit of a dump but i get
it all right so for you then so for you
let's say i was in a movie with charlize
theron and she was getting 15 million i
can't ask for 15 million as my first
movie i mean you should
just for you because that's a man you
should i totally get in terms of the
credits thing i was just genuinely like
everybody was like
julie
and i was like oh okay cool i mean so
you so you like you like charlize from
monster is that no he said that no
that's like anything he said that's what
they said i don't mind shortly staring
from reindeer games great deer games of
all movies
john frankenheimer's topic yeah oh she
was thank you
mad max she was hot as [ __ ] mad now she
was hot as [ __ ] even with shaved head
come on now even covered in dirt and
[ __ ] oh yeah but she had no arm and so
that was kind of weird that was possibly
hot all right so back to this mackin
also claimed she was exposed to a
culture of sexist behavior escalated by
one of her bosses matt pinock his former
p.a georgina chapman told the tribunal
of an occasion in which a black witch's
hat was left on mackin's desk after
their team had gone drinking one
afternoon that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that's it upon returning to work the
next morning mac and asked chapman if
she knew what had happened to which she
replied i told her that i did not know
but i suspected it was one of the drunk
team members because they were the only
people in that area of the office the
evening before well she doesn't even
know bro how catholic do you have to be
to care about a witch's hat dude
you're like dude a witch's hat oh my
[ __ ] god that's that's a bad omen
dude i just thought that was an
interesting part of the way is it the
halloween one the one with the colors
yeah that's [ __ ] crooked a little bit
i understand the 2.6 million now well i
gotta say ever since he said deutsche
bank dude google jeffrey epstein
deutsche bank
money laundering deutsche bank had to
pay a huge fine because they were
helping
funnel jeffrey epstein's [ __ ] sex
trafficking operation oh
that's why that name sounds so familiar
and they were down they don't give a
[ __ ] they're down thanks don't worry
about it look at wells fargo
you know they were setting up people for
uh accounts that they never asked for
what you didn't know oh that was huge
they got there so basically like you
open a checking account savings account
they're like oh but you also want this
account that account but they wouldn't
ask you they'll just sign you up for and
it's costing money well it was it was
more so because or based off what i saw
it was more so because um think of it as
like sales and quotas everybody that
they had hired in their bank their
television stuff they said you had to
reach a certain type of quota in terms
of opening new credit cards like fannie
mae and freddie mac like give me a break
yeah so then people who like weren't
hitting their quotas and were afraid to
get fired because they would also hire
like a bunch of like minorities and
stuff that wouldn't be able to get hired
at other banks or whatnot but those
people had to hit quotas so they started
signing up like their own parents
they're on this they're on that right
and then once they ran out of people to
like sign up because you only have so
many people pyramid scams exactly that's
exactly so then they started looking up
like dead people and random people to
open up accounts for so but i i think
that's that's a wells fargo
pr move because
it's from the top down basically they're
telling them dude just because go ahead
would do because i think congress people
ask how do you not know don't claim you
don't you didn't know it's your bank
it's still your responsibility so they
were fined three billion dollars
okay where that money goes have no clue
they have three billion but then because
of um our former supreme leaders
corporate tax break they um saved five
billion dollars that year
whoa so for them like we made two bills
they made two billion so banking when
they get fined when they get in trouble
they're like okay that's cool wow like
it's a loss this year but it's fine hey
look all i know is when i put my money
in the bank they use my money to make
ten percent no matter what and then you
know they give me nothing
so it feels good you know you you know
you get point zero zero zero one i think
that's pretty good so it feels good no
they're progressing 0.05 nowadays
and then people go how you guys think
you're making all this magic money
crypto and i'm like oh no no my money's
being used to make money and i'm getting
a cut of it for once actually
[ __ ] it's not a matter because
we are the bank [ __ ] that's it
and then people also click their heels
together they go wow did you hear my
credit card's gonna give me one percent
cash back
that's [ __ ] it's a magic trick isn't
it they're giving you they'll just give
you a little scrap because they're
they're using money to make 1.5 capital
one yeah
meanwhile they're charging you ten
dollars for a transaction that's right
did you guys see that letter i got
they're like congratulations you get a
high interest credit card i mean a a
savings account at
.025 percent that is high for them
point zero two five percent they're like
cut the plebs in give them point two
five percent they'll think it's great i
bet you gotta pre-qualify for that.025
just
just keep 10 million in there and you'll
be good yeah you'll be fine hey dude
when you when you're like 75 years old
and you can retire you're going to be
living life
you